from calorie count to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in the US and in India
this is food Wars
the smallest Pizza in the US is the
personal pan pizza and it is six inches
across in India our pizzas start at
personal size it's seven inches wide and
has four slices
the US also has a small pizza but only
with the gluten-free crust and it is
difficult 10 inches wide so depressing
looking
then we're on to the mediums a medium
pizza here in India is 10 inches and has
6 slices a U.S medium Pizza comes in at
12 inches wide this medium Pizza is
equal to the small pizza in the U.S
people in the US sometimes it's just
really hard not to stereotype you guys
next up in India we have
nothing because medium is our largest
size that's right we have only two sizes
personal or medium no large for us
because Pizza Hut is watching our weight
I guess
stereotype away my man because in the US
you know we got this large and it is 14
inches in diameter so America's largest
pizza is four inches wider than India's
largest that doesn't sound so bad
however if you calculate the surface
area of the two pizzas those few inches
make a big difference the India medium
has a surface area of 78.5 square inches
while the US large clocks in at
153.9 square inches to save you from
doing the mat that's a 96 increase that
means the U.S large pizza is nearly
double our Indian medium what the heck
Pizza Hut the type of crust you get
doesn't affect the width of the pizza
but how does it affect the value we're
going to weigh a medium hand tossed
Slice versus a medium pan crust slice to
see which one gives you more pizza for
your money all right I'm gonna do the
same with our pan and San Francisco
style pizzas uh they're medium size all
right so medium hand tossed weighs 94
grams
Pan the thick boy
Whoa 104 grams that's a difference of
what was the first one
uh that's a difference of this many
grams this one is fan style and it
weighs 78 grams this slice
weighs 66 grams fairly lighter and I
think this is because when they make
this pizza they press it down into the
pan and that's the San Francisco style
this weighs more and therefore is more
because it's more bread you got the
cheese and the sauce you want the fun
stuff right I don't know
oh boy this is gonna be trouble
[Music]
and on the menu at Pizza Hut India that
you will not find in the U.S and here
are all the Pizza Hut menu items from
the US you won't find in India let's
start off with the foundation of any
pizza the crust starting with the San
Francisco
signature style to my understanding it's
basically a pan pizza but they spressed
the dough in with their hands so it's
kind of a hand tossed next up we have
something very special it's a Schezwan
pan pizza
oh my God yeah I really like this it's
spicy really um just to give you some
comparison the way chicken tikka masala
was invented in the UK but clearly
inspired by Indian Cuisine Schezwan
sauce was actually invented here in
Kolkata by the Chinese community that
settled down here but it's obviously
inspired by Chinese cuisine and now it's
become part of Indian Cuisine we have
accepted it Holi and we eat it all
across India very exciting to see it
integrated into the Pizza Hut menu and
it actually tastes very good on this
pizza next up they have a stuffed cheese
crust Max with two x's for emphasis you
can already see that this thing is
loaded with cheese next to the cheese
alongside it there's like a sort of
creamy sauce which Pizza Hut is calling
Peruvian creamy sauce
whoa oh my God yeah this is decadent
food next up we have a stuffed crust
with veg Kebab that's right if you don't
know what Kebab is it's basically meat
that's cooked in like a Tandoor if you
don't know what a Tandoor is please go
watch the older episodes of food was
I've explained it eight times a lot of
people like to leave the crust behind
but I feel like pizza is making sure all
of the pizza is eaten because even this
looks like a dish in itself at this
point oh my God that's really yum and
the final option the stuffed crust with
a non-vegetarian kebab
as you can see this is what looks to be
chicken chic
oh that's the best of a lot
that was amazing oh my God Smash It
Pizza Hut that might be the best pizza
I've had on purva so far and I didn't
even eat the pizza apart we also have a
variety of crust options in the U.S
starting down here you saw it already
here it is again the hand tossed this to
me is like Classic this is the default
you guys don't have hand tossed moving
on thin and crispy I mean how much
they can't charge the same amount for
this right I don't think they should
moving on over here the original stuffed
crust they put cheese in the crust can
you believe that
it is it is solidified doesn't stop me
from biting into it
yeah yeah yeah last
and let's be honest least gluten-free
crust look I don't know what's gonna
gluten allergies and in my apologies if
you have one but look at this I'm just
like I'm sorry guys I mean is this that
much better I don't know how you can
enjoy this and for a limited time Pizza
in the US has Detroit style pizza let's
go let us go look at this are you
kidding me with this Detroit style pizza
what's Detroit style well they cook it
in a square pan that has like sides to
it it's like when you cook brownies in
every brownie is like a corner or end
piece it's like that for pizza so every
slice is gonna have the crispy crust on
the outside it's thicker one of my
favorite pizza Styles I'm glad Pizza is
doing it generous with the pepperoni
guys I appreciate it
foreign
not the best Detroit selfies I've ever
had but it's pretty good I think they go
bread cheese topping sauce these are the
toppings we found under the categories
classic favorites and Delight very
arbitrarily named but yeah let's jump
into it the first option is chicken
sausage smells really good a lot of
onions I love onions
hmm
it's pretty classic the next Pizza is
spiced paneer paneer if you don't know
is cottage cheese we make it all over
the place here in India and it's one of
our favorite ingredients we use it on
everything even pizzas
not very spicy but definitely it's got
like a Tangy twist to it next up we have
the veggie Feast it's got some herbed
onion capsicum and sweet corn
this is like such a wholesome chill
Pizza it's definitely a classic it's
something your mom would make at home
next up we have the veggie Tandoori
which I have already taken a bite of we
got this one with the Schezwan crust so
it's definitely spicier than the typical
pan pizza you'll get and I already
tasted it and I told you I loved it I
love the spice next up we have spiced
chicken
meatables it's a very straightforward
pizza but we got it with the cheese
burst filling next up we have the
chicken and corn Delight it already has
the word delight in the name so I'm
assuming it should be a delight but I'll
be the judge of that capsicum chicken
just strewn across and corn
it's got too much going on I would say
personally I would not order a pizza
like this next up to round it all off
this is the double chicken sausage pizza
am I wrong in saying that this just
looks like a boring version of the
normal chicken sausage pizza which has
onions and this feels a lot better we
have a pepperoni pizza that is made of
pork and that chicken and a pepperoni
lovers Pizza which one has more
pepperoni
can't tell the Supreme Pizza it has
pepperoni mushrooms green peppers onions
and that's it but if that's not Supreme
enough for you we have the super supreme
which now they've introduced black
olives meat lovers baby meat lovers you
got pepperoni you got bacon you got
sausage I bet there's something else on
there that I don't know another meat I
just it's beautiful this next Pizza is
the veggie lovers and I absolutely hate
it now you want veggies go get a salad
then put on pizza like you're not
fooling anyone right Backyard barbecue
chicken Yulie do you have enough b-roll
I think it's barbecue chicken but I
think they use barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce genius genius
this is so good oh yeah a buffalo
chicken it looks like surprisingly good
Pizza does not have a straight Hawaiian
pizza on the menu the only thing they
have is Hawaiian chicken I see obviously
chicken I see a pineapple
I think I say ham yep I think Hawaiian
should just be pineapple and bacon if
you want to throw some chicken on that's
fine but if you have a strong opinion
either four against pineapple on Pizza
you're wrong it's a perfectly fine
topping I don't know why everyone gets
so worked up about it more pizzas and
these are all part of the Signature
Collection
um there are 11 pizzas in front of me
two four six okay first off the country
Feast um it looks super Saucy it's all
loaded with vegetables there's mushrooms
capsicum onion sweet corn roasted
Peppers everything that you want on a
country themed Pizza all right next up
we have Tandoori paneer if you remember
in the previous categories we had spiced
paneer so all I'm looking for is why is
this different
oh my God
that's really yum next up is the veggie
lover it's basically got tomato onion
capsicum mushrooms and some red paprika
and hopefully a whole lot of flavor
[Music]
it's underwhelming I'm gonna be honest
next up we have chicken tikka everybody
knows chicken
it's a bit too strong too Tangy and I
think they could have gone with a
thinner layer of sauce next up we have
the Malai chicken tikka Malai is
basically cream so Malai kebabs they
basically Grill the chicken and they
pour Malai on top we have the chicken
pepperoni double paneer Supreme you like
paneer you like Supreme clothes well
this has double of it minus the clothes
veggie Supreme everybody in India has
heard of this pizza this is a painting I
can genuinely see this on the wall of an
art gallery this capsicum there's olives
this corn there's onions there's corn
again veg Kebab surprise I'm curious to
know what's going to be surprising about
this
surprise surprise it is Bland and now on
to our penultimate signature Pizza this
is the chicken tikka Supreme woohoo
basically what they've done is they've
taken four different kinds of chicken
and they put it on a pizza and finally
in the line of signature pizzas we have
Triple Chicken Feast it has
all of the above ingredients and we've
also gone the extra mile and taken it
with a chicken stuffing in the crust
overall Pizza Hut has actually killed it
I think all the ingredients are tasted
Super Fresh all the meat has also tasted
really soft and Juicy and Delicious and
the sauce has been consistently yum
throughout damn Pizza Hut
good job as mentioned before currently
have a Detroit style pizza at the U.S
Pizza Hut this is what it looks like two
slices are missing I skipped lunch and
breakfast to be honest for those of you
outside of the United States Detroit is
the city of Michigan they have their own
style of pizza I really enjoy it you can
also get it as a supreme Detroit style
and a meaty Deluxe Detroit style and I
didn't get them because it all looks
exactly like this one fun option on the
Pizza Hut India menu is the new range of
momomia pizzas which are pan pizzas with
Momos baked into the crust now if you
don't know what Momos are they're
basically dumplings from Nepal and Tibet
they served all across India and they've
become huge favorites for everybody over
here they've also given a Schezwan sauce
to the side which is what you typically
eat with Momos
hmm
that ain't right I don't see how this is
working I can't think of a single
Italian who would put a pocket of
ravioli on top of a pizza and then bake
them together
and this is effectively what that is we
also have a range of flavor fun personal
pan pizzas that you can get with a host
of new flavors starting off with classic
corn next up we have the classic onion
and capsicum Tandoori mushroom and corn
so it looks similar to this but they use
Tandoori sauce and they've added
mushrooms next up we have the classic
paneer onion and capsicum then we have
the classic chicken sausage but personal
pan sized next we have the Italian
pepperoni and onion and just a reminder
that the pepperoni that they've used is
chicken pepperoni tandoori chicken tikka
and onion and the classic Loaded Chicken
Delight personally
I wouldn't order these pans I would get
the larger pizzas because they tasted
way better on top of set menu items we
can also customize our pizzas in unique
ways for example if you don't want
tomato sauce as your base you can sub it
out for creamy garlic parmesan barbecue
sauce remember from before buffalo sauce
or a no sauce option if you are a maniac
and if you want you can specify light
regular or extra sauce unfortunately we
can't change the sauces on our pizza
bases but we have a bunch of custom
toppings that you will not find in the
US like baby corn sweet corn herb
veggies spice paneer and veg kebab
and we also have exclusive toppings you
cannot get in India for instance we have
pepperoni which is pork Italian sausage
has pork bacon uh I believe it's pork
meatballs beef and pork ham pork and
then beef
and pork then the vegetables we got
white onion we got pineapple which is a
fruit and we have banana peppers which I
don't know if it's a fruit or a
vegetable or a pepper our peppers fruit
whenever we have the option of
customizations on food Wars we like to
combine all of our exclusive ingredients
to make an india-only pizza so this
pizza has a Schezwan base with baby corn
wedge Kebab spiced paneer and herbed
veggies it looks pretty gnarly I'm not
gonna lie but let's see how it tastes
[Music]
hmm I can see why Pizza Hut didn't put
this officially on their menu because
maybe the ingredients go don't go that
well together but hey this is an India
only Pizza Hut pizza and that means
something and of course we had to create
our own us only pizza so the thin crispy
base creamy garlic Parmesan sauce beef
bacon white onion and everyone's
favorite vegetable banana peppers
this looks like a cartoon Pizza
okay is that bad it's not great I
wouldn't get it uh yeah it tastes like
onion and bacon don't get this oh
Pizza Hut has a bunch of sides so let's
start off with the breads first off we
have cheese garlic bread then we have a
spicy Supreme cheese garlic bread it's
basically cheese melted on top of a
garlic bread baguette it's got some
green chili and some chopped onions it's
very delicious when it's hot Mexican
garlic bread sticks oregano sprinkled on
top some jalapenos some chopped olives
and onions it looks really delicious
creamy garlic breadsticks and finally we
have garlic bread sticks in a little
packet that says garlic bread sticks
the U.S Pizza Hut only offers regular
breadsticks and cheese sticks so in fact
the only actual exclusive side that we
have in the U.S is fries we have a bunch
of other sites including baked cheesy
Momo's wedge and baked cheesy Momos
non-ridge
that's a potent smell you know what
it's not half bad next up we have potato
poppers which are pretty much tater tots
we have the indie rock and roll veg and
the indie rock and roll non-veg this is
basically a roll but I like how the wrap
is kind of thin
no again it's quite good next up we have
the zesty paneer pocket and the zesty
chicken pocket uh these are pretty much
like pizza pockets there's some mint
Mayo some normal Mayo some cream cheese
chicken and jalapenos we have jalapeno
poppers I imagine they're just filled
with cheese and some jalapeno bits oh I
did not expect that consistency and that
brings us to an old classic chicken
wings spicy baked chicken wings so I
suppose they're a healthier alternative
Wing Street Wings yes both traditional
and boneless you can get them in the
following flavors lemon pepper oh let's
go lemon pepper
I usually don't like lemon pepper but
these are pretty good ooh honey barbecue
he's getting these things out like
condensation uh oh the medium Buffalo
ooh Cajun style
[Music]
just okay spicy garlic but naked that's
wings with nothing on it why would you
do that I don't know Buffalo burning hot
three Flames
um
this should be your medium oh wait
yeah okay
sweet chili am I sweating I feel like
I'm sweating
they're all just
you know I mean I like wings maybe maybe
my wing standards are too high garlic
parmesan oh
oh
my God I mean the sauce like pasta sauce
it's really thick and it's got a lot of
flavor to it but it's just like sitting
in the sauce so either you get a
mouthful of sauce or none and these come
in portions of 6 12 18 or 36. and next
up on the menu you can also find a range
of pastas starting with the creamy
mushroom
you know what if I have to listen to
this so will you all
get some of the boom mic
[Music]
decent pasta for a fast food restaurant
they have a Cheesy Comfort veg pasta and
a Cheesy Comfort chicken pasta It's too
gooey we have the spice tomato twist veg
pasta and the spice tomato twist non-veg
pasta if you come to Pizza Hut to order
pasta
I hope you never cross paths nikhil you
have no idea we absolutely love our
carbs in this country and as you can see
we have bowls and bowls of carbs that we
call Pasta you can get four exclusive
oven baked pastas add pot pasta Hut at
Pizza Hut
I'm not eating any of these they all
taste terrible all right the end you can
get a oven baked chicken alfredo don't
get this or if you don't like chicken
you can just get
cheesy Alfredo and then of course we
have the Italian Meats pasta which is
pepperoni and Italian sausage I mean oh
oh Italy oh Italy
I'm so sorry and lastly the oven baked
veggie pasta I mean this this is this is
a doorstop
I I can't stand the Pizza Hut pasta I
cannot stand it you see the sauces you
know what time it is
starting down here get yourself blue
cheese sauce then get Ranch oh a garlic
sauce we can have a honey barbecue sauce
a medium buffalo sauce and a side of
marinara just for a dip in your
breadsticks and also the icing the
Cinnabon icing for the Cinnabons and
there's a note that says I really want
to see Joe dipping some pizza in the
frosting and eat it
ah
give me this
oh
excellent at first I was like yuck but
this is kind of good and now on to dips
your dips
first off we have tomato ketchup
then we have a mayonnaise fun fact it's
veg mayonnaise doesn't have any egg
because a huge population of this
country is pure vegetarians which means
that they don't eat anything from an
animal
even egg then we have a cheese dip and
finally it's a Schezwan sauce and if so
they serve it with the Momos they serve
it with a bunch of other things
yeah we got this Rich you're not gonna
find in India that includes down here
the cinnamon sticks they're like
breadsticks only cinnamony
get your mind out of the gutter and
moving on we have here are the Cinnabon
mini cinnamon rolls this is the triple
chocolate brownie
if I had to guess two pounds what you
got here the ultimate chocolate chip
cookie
right
it's like a frisbee
and for all you Sweetie Pies out there
with sweet tooths here are India's
exclusive desserts starting with a
charcoal lava cake baby
[Music]
molten the chocolate cake in Domino's
much better next up you get a whole
range of ice cream some quality walls
one of India's biggest ice cream
manufacturers you can get a tiny tub of
chocolate Supreme sundae then you can
get a Coronado a cone super delicious
and I really love the end of this
because it's just a block of chocolate
and I used to fight over this with my
friends then you get a magnum everybody
loves a magnum and finally you can even
get a family pack of ice cream
soda last exclusive are of course the
drinks both countries have Pepsi but the
pizza in the US you can also get Wild
Cherry Pepsi Orange Crush
Mountain Dew baby Sierra Mist which they
didn't have and Aquafina here in Pizza
Hut India our exclusive drink options
are Pepsi 7Up mirinda and Pepsi black
they also serve an iced tea at the
restaurant but they don't deliver it
unfortunately I would have gone for the
iced tea
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at Pizza
Hut's pricing particularly some clever
marketing tricks they're using to make
you believe you're getting more value
for money than you actually are in the
US a medium cheese pizza and the pan
crust will cost you
13.49 in India a medium Margarita Pizza
will cost you 319 rupees which is
currently 3.93 US dollars that means
over here you are paying 11.9 cents per
square inch of pizza while over here in
India you're just paying 4.4 cents per
square inch of pizza that makes a U.S
pizza 170 more expensive generally with
pizza the more you buy the cheaper it
gets a US large has a surface area of
153.9 square inches and costs
15.49 that brings the cost per square
inch down to 10 cents making it 15
cheaper than the medium ladies and
gentlemen it's time for pizza pop quiz
which has the higher surface area one
medium pizza or two personal pizzas if
you said two personal pizzas
congratulations you're an idiot because
when it comes to calculating the surface
area of a circle small changes in
diameter can create huge differences in
surface area on the Pizza Hut India
website you can get a combo offer of two
personal pan pizzas for rupees 279
however a medium Pizza costs pretty much
the same but I guess if you want two
different flavors of pizza it makes
sense to go with the combo
and this medium cheese pan crust pizza
it is 1 940 calories 79 grams of total
fat 33 grams of saturated fat 224 grams
of carbs and the sodium oh boy
3480 milligrams a medium Margarita Pizza
in India will cost you 1 377 calories
total fat 40.29 grams of its saturates
are 14.7 grams carbohydrates 192 grams
and
2717 milligrams of sodium yikes now the
American stats look a lot worse but I do
want to point out that our medium is
much larger than India's so if you break
it down per square inch you'll see that
the US version does have more fat and
more saturated fat but India's Pizza
actually contains more calories carbs
and sodium but what about the most
calorific item on the Indian menu if you
really want to mess up your day you have
to order the medium wedge surprise Kebab
pizza with wedge Kebab stuffed crust a
whole one of these pizzas will contain
2673 calories that's
133.65 of your daily caloric intake
allowance oh my God okay the calories
are high but the sodium is even higher
that is
6344 milligrams of sodium in here which
is 275 percent of your daily recommended
allowance what about the most calorific
Pizza in the US well that would be a
large pan crusted meat lovers which this
isn't so imagine it bigger and thicker
okay an entire one of these contains a
whopping
3570 calories it's 178 your daily
allowance and the sodium is even worse
than that of India's There's 7 150
milligrams of sodium in here that is
298 your daily recommended amount but so
this speeds up it's not particularly
round it's shaped like a one two three
four five hexagon look at that
just a fun fact in case you're a
geometry nerd